I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense then what do we do like what is
what do you feel like is the next step
then with all this stuff in mind and
this is fake this is real whatever like
how do you want to walk forward in your
life and how do you want to how do you
want to be remembered I think the
biggest thing that we can do is live in
the present now because you're
absolutely right we don't know any of
those answers and so without knowing
those answers it's really hard to plan
accordingly so I think it's so much
easier to focus on the things that we
can control and the things that we do
you know rather than the things that we
don't and you know we can control
everyday in the present and like of the
things that we can control in the
present some of those lend well to
building the future that we want to
build so I think we all really just need
to tune into ourselves and make sure
that we're still connecting with other
people and I think connecting with other
people is so much of how we grow and in
this world that says we're more
connected than ever I think so many
people out there feel less connected and
I think it's really important that we
need to keep on staying connected
because it's good for our minds it's
good for our bodies it's good for our
psyche but honestly it's also good for
like if automation is something that
you're worried about like computers
can't connect people otherwise we'd all
be feeling more connected than ever
actually because of social media because
of algorithms because of these things
and so like if you really want to stay
nash necessary in an age of automation
like you either have to be creative or
you have to connect people how do you do
that uh-huh well my creativity manifests
in a lot of different forums I I mean of
course obviously through photos and
videos that I share on Instagram and
yoga sequences but also just through
creative thinking like it's so easy to
think about things the way that we're
taught or think about things the way
that we learned them in school and I
think it's so important to be creative
in the way that you think about things
and creative in the way that you view a
problem like maybe rather than trying to
solve it the traditional way when that's
really hard you get creative and find an
easier way to solve it like I'm really
inspired by trying to solve complex
problems and that's also I think a big
way that I connect with people to tie
the two together is I think that I've
sort of become inadvertently a
relationship coach to so many of my
friends and it's because I really like
problem-solving especially when they're
complicated so they come to me with
these really complex problems that
they're dealing with in the present yeah
and talk about math problems you're
talking about emotional problems I'm
talking about life people problems you
have problems yes problems I mean I
think so often we work harder when we
could be working smarter but it's
because we're all like in our own narrow
perspective and so I think I'm really
good at connecting people by being the
person that they can come to and ask
them questions to help them get out of
these like horse blinders that they're
wearing and I think just through I
creatively solve problems and share that
information with people and it all sort
of feeds into my creativity and helps me
connect with people and helps other
people connect with each other
[Music]